owns this local Kebab shop in killis in
Southeastern turkey four years ago his
place was hit by a rocket fired by a
Kurdish ypg Fighters across the border
in Syria at the time Turkish and Syrian
opposition forces were fighting against
a group in Northern Syria's African
region he remembered that attack when
five rockets were fired at killis on the
Turkish Syrian border earlier this week
our children are our only concern in
their psychology otherwise no rocket
from ypg or isil can fear us we are used
to it and have faith in our state
but some people especially women are
more concerned about those Rockets
we never had Terror attacks before it
was a peaceful city until we were thrown
into a war fast the refugees then
Rockets being fired our children go to
school here just one bomb in our city
could change everything
the latest attack was carried out in
retaliation by the ypg which Ankara
regards as an offshoot of the band
Kurdistan Workers Party or pkk it came
after turkey launched on a campaign
against a group in response to a bomb
attack in Istanbul earlier this month
now president
has promised to launch a grand operation
to secure a safe Corridor along his
country's Southern border that is free
of ypg presence
Louis who moved here from Syria 10 years
ago is concerned a large-scale operation
could displace more people on both sides
of the Border
when isil targeted killers in 2016 her
cousin lost three of his children
syrians and Turks temporarily evacuated
the city there was no life I support an
operation if it's going to be safe by
Fair relocating it's difficult curious
was heavily targeted by isil in 2016
when the art group controlled parts of
Northern Aleppo but people we met here
say they won't be intimidated
many people here in Killers say they
support their government's fight against
what it refers to as terrorism but if
president Ardon launches a full-fledged
ground offensive against the ypg in
Northern Syria border cities like killis
May once again become battle Thrones
Southeastern turkey